(Musique)
Ou Orion, le chasseur.
Ou celle du Taureau.
(Musique)
Nous vivons dans un univers musical
et nous pouvons l'utiliser pour le vivre avec un autre regard
et partager cette perspective avec plus de personnes.
Je vais vous montrer.
(Fin de la musique)
Quand je dis que je suis astrophysicien,
les gens sont plutôt impressionnés.
Et quand j'ajoute que je suis aussi musicien, ça ne les étonne pas.
(Rires)
Tout le monde semble savoir
qu'il y a un lien profond entre la musique et l'astronomie.
C'est une idée ancienne, en fait.
Ça remonte à Pythagore, il y a 2 000 ans.
Vous le connaissez grâce à son théorème,
le théorème de Pythagore.
(Rires)
Il a dit ceci :
« Il y a de la géométrie dans le son émis par des cordes
et de la musique dans l'espace entre deux sphères. »
Il pensait littéralement
que le mouvement des planètes le long de la sphère céleste
créait une musique harmonieuse.
Si on lui demandait pourquoi nous n'entendions rien,
il disait qu'on n'entend pas
parce qu'on ignore ce que c'est de ne pas l'entendre.
On ne connaît pas le silence.
C'est quand il y a une panne d'électricité
qu'on s'aperçoit que le bruit du frigo est énervant.
Vous pourriez le croire.
Mais tout le monde ne l'a pas cru, Aristote, notamment.
(Rires)
Véridique.
Je vais vous citer ses mots exacts :
« C'est une idée sympa
mais si une chose aussi vaste et immense que les cieux eux-mêmes
bougeaient, produisaient des sons,
non seulement ce serait audible,
mais en plus, ce serait insoutenable. »
Nous existons, donc il n'y a pas de musique des sphères.
Il pensait au demeurant, que l'unique rôle du cerveau est de rafraîchir le sang.
Ça ne le crédibilise pas.
(Rires)
Mais je pense que d'une certaine manière, ils ont tous les deux raison.
Commençons donc par comprendre ce qui rend la musique musicale.
Ça peut vous sembler bizarre comme question
mais ne vous êtes-vous jamais demandé pourquoi
certaines notes jouées ensemble sont agréables, sont consonantes.
Comme ces deux-ci --
(Musique)
Alors que d'autres sont discordantes, dissonantes.
Comme celles-ci.
(Musique)
N'est-ce pas ?
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi y a-t-il des notes ?
Pourquoi peut-on être accordé ou désaccordé ?
Eh bien, la réponse à cette question
a été résolue par Pythagore en personne.
Regardez la corde sur la gauche.
Si vous la pincez,
elle produit une note en oscillant très rapidement d'avant en arrière.
(Note musicale)
Mais si on coupe la corde en deux, on obtient deux cordes
qui oscillent deux fois plus vite.
Ça produit une note associée.
Trois fois plus vite,
quatre fois plus vite --
(Notes musicales)
Le secret de l'harmonie musicale réside donc dans des ratios, tout simplement :
plus le ratio est simple,
plus agréables, consonantes, ces deux notes seront, jouées ensemble.
Plus le ratio est complexe, plus le son devient dissonant.
C'est l'interaction entre la tension et le relâchement,
ou la consonance et la dissonance,
qui crée ce qu'on appelle la musique.
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Ce n'est pas tout.
(Rires)
Les deux éléments musicaux que nous appelons la hauteur et le rythme,
sont en fait deux versions de la même chose.
Je vais vous monter.
(Rythme lent)
C'est bien un rythme.
Observez ce qui se passe quand on accélère.
(Le rythme accélère progressivement)
(Son aiguë)
(Son devenant grave)
(Rythme lent)
Quand un rythme a lieu plus de 20 fois par seconde,
le cerveau bascule.
Il n'entend plus un rythme, mais il entend une hauteur.
Quel est le rapport avec l'astronomie ?
C'est là qu'on parle du système TRAPPIST-1.
C'est un système d'exoplanètes découvert en février 2017.
Tout le monde est super excité par les sept planètes de la taille de la Terre
en orbite à proximité d'une étoile naine presque rouge.
On pense que trois de ces planètes
ont la bonne température pour l'eau liquide.
Elles sont si proches que d'ici quelques années,
on devrait pouvoir détecter des éléments dans leur atmosphère
comme l'oxygène et le méthane, des signes de vie potentielle.
Une des caractéristiques du système TRAPPIST-1 est qu'il est petit.
Voici les orbites des planètes au centre rocheux
de notre système solaire : Mercure, Vénus, la Terre et Mars.
Les sept planètes de TRAPPIST-1 de dimension terrestre
sont toutes à l'intérieur de l'orbite de Mercure.
Je vais agrandir cela par un facteur 25
pour vous permettre d'observer les planètes de TRAPPIST-1.
Leur dimension est plus proche de celle de Jupiter et de ses lunes,
même si on parle de sept planètes de la taille de la Terre.
Des illustrations artistiques fabuleuses sont une autre raison de s'enthousiasmer.
Il y a de l'eau à l'état liquide, de la glace, un peu de terre.
On peut même imaginer nager sous un soleil couchant idyllique.
Tout le monde est excité
jusqu'à ce que, quelques mois plus tard, une autre publication paraisse
et explique que ça ressemble davantage à ceci.
(Rires)
Nous avions des indices
que certaines régions étaient sans doute constituées de magma
et que l'étoile centrale émettait des rayons X très dangereux.
Des rayons X qui stérilisent la planète de toute vie
et la dépouillent de son atmosphère.
Heureusement, il y a quelques mois, en 2018,
de nouvelles publications ont apporté des mesures plus raffinées.
On a découvert que le paysage ressemble sans doute à ceci.
(Rires)
Nous savons donc que plusieurs planètes ont de grandes réserves d'eau --
des océans planétaires --
et que plusieurs ont des atmosphères épaisses.
C'est donc un endroit approprié pour chercher une vie potentielle.
Mais il y a une chose encore plus motivante,
surtout pour moi :
TRAPPIST-1 est une chaîne résonnante.
Ça signifie que chaque fois que la planète la plus éloignée fait deux orbites,
la suivante en fait trois,
et la suivante quatre,
et la suivante six, neuf, 15 et 24.
Il y a donc beaucoup de ratios simples entre les orbites de ces planètes.
Quand on augmente leur vitesse, on obtient des rythmes.
Un battement pour chaque orbite accomplie.
Nous savons aussi que si on accélère davantage,
on va produire des tons musicaux
et dans ce cas uniquement,
les tons vont bien s'allier,
créant une harmonie mélodieuse, presque humaine.
Écoutons maintenant TRAPPIST-1.
Vous allez d'abord entendre une note pour chaque orbite de chaque planète.
Gardez à l'esprit
que cette musique provient du système.
Je ne crée pas des tons ou des rythmes.
Je les emmène simplement dans la plage d'audition humaine.
Et quand les sept planètes seront là,
vous allez voir --
vous allez entendre un battement chaque fois que deux planètes s'alignent.
C'est le moment où elles se rapprochent
et s'attirent par gravitation.
(Note)
(Deux notes)
(Trois notes)
(Quatre notes)
(Cinq notes)
(Six notes)
(Sept notes)
(Battement de tambour)
(Fin de la musique)
Voilà le son de l'étoile -- sa lumière est convertie en son.
Vous vous demandez peut-être comment cela est possible.
Un orchestre est une bonne analogie.
Quand tous les musiciens se réunissent et commencent à jouer,
ils ne le font pas directement.
Ils doivent d'abord s'accorder.
Ils doivent s'assurer
que le son de leur instrument résonne avec les autres,
et une chose semblable a eu lieu au début de l'existence de TRAPPIST-1.
En période de formation,
les planètes sont en orbite autour d'un disque de gaz
et tout en restant à l'intérieur,
elles pouvaient glisser autour
et ajuster leur orbite à celles des voisines
jusqu'à être parfaitement en harmonie.
Heureusement, car ce système est si compact --
beaucoup de masse dans un espace ténu --
si tous les aspects de leurs orbites n'étaient pas en harmonie parfaite,
elles bouleverseraient rapidement leurs orbites mutuelles,
menant ainsi à la destruction du système.
C'est donc la musique qui maintient ce système en vie,
et ses habitants potentiels.
Quel est le son de notre système solaire ?
Ça me fait mal d'être le premier à vous l'avouer, mais c'est moche.
(Rires)
D'abord,
notre système solaire a une échelle beaucoup plus grande.
Pour écouter les huit planètes,
il faut commencer avec Neptune, au plus bas dans notre plage d'audition,
et finir en haut avec Mercure,
à la limite des aigus audibles par notre ouïe.
De plus, nos planètes ne sont pas très compactes,
elles sont très éloignées l'une de l'autre,
et donc, elles n'ont pas eu besoin d'ajuster leurs orbites.
Elles jouent donc leur propre note aléatoirement.
Voici ce que ça donne, hélas.
(Note)
C'est Neptune.
(Deux notes)
Uranus.
(Trois notes)
Saturne.
(Quatre notes)
Jupiter.
Et juste après, Mars.
(Cinq notes)
(Six notes)
La Terre.
(Sept notes)
Vénus.
(Huit notes)
Et voilà Mercure.
Oui, oui, j'arrête.
(Rires)
C’était en fait le rêve de Kepler.
Johannes Kepler est la personne
qui a compris les lois régissant le mouvement des planètes.
Il était fasciné par l’idée
qu’il existe un lien entre la musique, l’astronomie et la géométrie.
Il a consacré un ouvrage entier
à la recherche de toute harmonie musicale parmi les planètes du système solaire
et c’était vraiment compliqué.
C’eût été beaucoup plus facile s’il avait vécu sur TRAPPIST-1
ou bien alors
sur K2-138.
C’est un nouveau système découvert en janvier 2018
avec cinq planètes,
et comme TRAPPIST-1,
elles se sont harmonisées au début de leur existence.
Elles sont en harmonie
dans une structure harmonique proposée par Pythagore lui-même,
il y a plus de 2 000 ans.
Mais le système doit son nom à Kepler
car c'est le télescope Kepler qui l'a découvert.
Donc, ces quelques derniers milliards d'années,
elles ont perdu leur harmonie,
comme TRAPPIST-1, en fait.
Je vous propose donc de remonter dans le temps
et imaginer le son qu'elles auraient produit
au moment de leur formation.
(Musique)
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Vous vous demandez sans doute jusqu'où on peut aller
et dans quelle mesure il y a de la musique dans l'espace.
C'est ce qui m'intriguait l'automne dernier
quand je travaillais au planétarium de l'université de Toronto,
et qu'une artiste, Robyn Rennie, et sa fille, Erin, m'ont contacté.
Robyn adore le ciel la nuit.
Mais elle ne peut plus le voir correctement depuis 13 ans
car elle a perdu la vue.
Elles se demandaient si je pouvais les aider.
J'ai réuni tous les sons que l'univers évoquait chez moi
et j'ai créé : « Notre univers musical ».
C'est une séance musicale du planétarium
qui explore les rythmes et les harmonies du cosmos.
Ceci a tant bouleversé Robyn
qu'une fois rentrée à la maison,
elle a peint cette toile fabuleuse pour illustrer son expérience.
Je l'ai ensuite défigurée sur le poster en y ajoutant Jupiter.
(Rires)
Bien...
Dans cette représentation, j'emmène les gens, quelle que soit leur vue,
dans une visite auditive de l'univers,
du ciel étoilé jusqu'aux confins de l'univers observable.
Ce n'est que la première étape d'une odyssée musicale
pour découvrir l'univers d'un regard neuf et d'une ouïe nouvelle.
J'espère vous rencontrer en chemin.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)